Jersey Shore's Ronnie ortiz-magro has
been granted an emergency restraining
order against ex-girlfriend Jen Harley
this in response to an alleged assault
by Harley Saturday night at his home
attorneys for ortiz-magro said in a
statement quote at the time miss Harley
entered his home while he was sleeping
and started viciously assaulting him the
restraining order is in effect until
February 25th Harley is represented by
high-profile attorney Lisa bloom who
released their own statement claiming
quote contact that Ronnie Ortiz had with
Gen Harley recently was in violation of
the restraining order in effect against
him adding quote Gen just wants to raise
her baby in peace the couple share one
year old daughter Ariana
this new incident comes after
ortiz-magro was arrested for alleged
domestic violence in October he pleaded
not guilty the following month
ortiz-magro spoke with et last year
about co-parenting with Harley for the
sake of their daughter let's talk about
your relationship though with her mom
and everything that you guys have gone
through where what is the status of your
relationship today um you know right now
she's always gonna be the mother of my
child and you know I feel like me and
her we're always gonna have love for
each other but I think we're just at a
point that you know I think we're just
trying to figure our selves out and you
know I think right now we're both
happier in the situation that we're in
you know and I have a lot of time to
focus on myself and focus on my daughter
focus on work and I think that right now
that's the best place in the mark that's
my estate for me to be in to be honest
with you
[Music]